la menace planait depuis des semaines la
voix dans la voilà donc finalement sur
le point de se concrétiser en réaction
aux annonces reus les ministres de
l'union européenne
s'apprête à adopter aujourd'hui un
premier train de sanctions contre la
russie sanctions en cours de discussion
dans toujours qui pourrait concerner des
centaines de personnes portaient aussi
sur l'interdiction des transactions sur
les obligations russes les ambassadeurs
des états membres se sont réunis dans la
matinée en amont d'un conseil d'urgence
des ministres les affaires étrangères de
lieu ce sera cet après midi à
paris en attendant en attendant le
chancelier allemand elle sait d'ores et
déjà exprimé ce matin olaf scholz qui a
donné le ton déjà avec cette annonce
importante la mise sur pause du projet
nord stream 2 écoutez le
regard des derniers développements nous
devons réévaluer la situation de nord
stream 2
j'ai demandé au ministère de l'économie
de retirer le rapport sur la sécurité de
la fourniture à lagence des réseaux
fédéraux
cela peut paraître un peu technocratique
mais c'est la première étape nécessaire
pour s'assurer que ce gazoduc ne sera
pas certifiée et sans certification nord
stream ii ne pourra pas opéré